the lady of the last four days she's won
four games in a row after a bad loss
karissa
this could only be a dream result you
must be on cloud nine
yeah i mean
i really
i didn't expect to win all my games
after after that bad loss i was kind of
like
damn playing like a 1900 out here i'll
be lucky to
to not lose any points in this
tournament but uh
i think i managed to turn it around yeah
did you turn it around i think you have
to turn it around
i think without question you'll
you uh before looking ahead let's tell
us about this game uh you played very
aggressively from the start queenside
castling going with g4 and getting g5 in
was this in your opening prep
um
i mean a little bit this is kind of just
what i normally play i think like
castling queen side should be the main
line in the position
and
um
and i feel like after i play h3 black
usually has to has to meet it with h4
just to stop g4 because
after i get g4 in it could get kind of
dangerous for her i think i misplayed it
a little bit but uh
but yeah i think that uh that g-pawn
didn't end up being annoying for her
you then stopped when she she kind of
stopped you in your tracks and played
two quiet moves
a3 and king to b1
and then she went into a deep thing and
played bishop to h2 when you saw that
bishop land there
what were you feeling about this
position
um i mean i was kind of annoyed because
in the in the previous position i was
considering between like
c4 and king b1 and
like my whole idea was like kind of what
happened in the game to play c4 c5 and
then go for some sort d5 break
um
but since she played bishop h2 i kind of
have to waste the tempo moving my my
rook and uh and then her bishop can go
back to like ba and then i don't have
that extra c5 tempo attacking the bishop
but
um but it didn't take long for this move
to actually happen she played her bishop
back
and you did go for it here i think
the engines were giving bishop d5 in
that position to play bishop f3
but instead you played
she didn't play that she just dropped
her bishop back which looked like it
signaled a loss of a tempo and then
suddenly it was all you a couple of
moves in you were able to play for the
c5 against her b5 and then suddenly here
was the dramatic moment after g5 queen
a4 queen d2 not training queens f5 and
now you blasted with d5 you must have
been excited to see this line on the
board
yeah i mean i don't think queen a4 is
very good just because it allows me to
get like that knight c3 in with the
tempo um just what happened in the game
right
and
yeah i mean after after d5 i feel like i
have to be
like much better if not totally winning
and we saw you play very direct chess
here picking things off and then trading
down
you weren't so bothered by the knight
showing up in the game it was such a bad
piece on g6
we were in the studio and especially at
the table we were saying why would you
bring the knight into the game
what was your thinking as you traded and
allow the night to be centralized um
i mean i felt like
like okay this is kind of what i
calculated like queen f4 right maybe
black's like
best chance for activity is knight c4
knight g6 is pretty passive but i feel
like that knight is just
it's like not very good on c4 i have
queen c7 ideas i have like rick takes d5
right away here too and like
h4 is also hanging so
so i didn't think she would go for this
um
well the engine thought this was
terrible as well for her so so you
proved to be correct
and then it was basically a train ride
forward after that and you were able to
get everything you wanted and win the
game you've won
four in a row
you've
won six games which i would think is
slightly more than you've ever won in
this tournament
just a tad
uh you've defeated three former champs
you face
a fourth champion najib kidzi in the
next round
no one in the women's game has ever
defeated four former champions not to
try to put any pressure on you
will you go for it against naji
um
you know i think i'll keep quiet in case
in case she decides to watch us you know
the tournament's not over yet
god gotta stay smart about things
indeed indeed we we tried to trick you
there but you didn't fall for it
congrats you're having a fantastic
performance it's not over yet good luck
in the rest of the games thank you good
luck carissa very